[Music]
in our special series school matters
we're looking at a struggle millions of
parents face
how to afford food for their children
during the summer the census bureau says
kids in up to 13 million households
did not have enough food to eat and less
than 20 percent of children
who qualified for free and reduced lunch
got the meals they needed
nancy cordes looks at why it's been so
difficult to keep those nutrition
programs running
at full capacity during remote learning
nancy good morning
good morning anthony and here's another
eye-opening number for you from one
study that found that
when schools went to remote learning in
the spring they
served nearly 400 million fewer meals
than they had the previous school year
and with so many schools
still engaged in distance learning this
fall there is a real concern among
nutrition officers from coast to coast
that the 30 million kids who rely on
school lunches
some of them might be going hungry
in cincinnati ohio 85 percent of
students
qualified for food assistance even
before the pandemic hit
hey there kiddos how are you when the
schools shut down
officials made sure no student lived
more than a mile
from a pickup site like this one but
still
the city served just 10 percent of the
meals it did when schools were open
i don't know what we would have done
without it ashley o'neill runs a food
truck with her husband
the mom of two worries about sending her
daughters back to school
in person starting this week anxiety is
high
we don't really know what to expect i
don't have a nine to five
where i absolutely have to be there and
for the people that do have that i'm
sure they're freaking out right now
23.4 million families nationwide have
lost income due to the pandemic many
children
qualifying for the national school lunch
program for the first time
because their family is suddenly making
less than about 48 thousand dollars a
year
community groups have stepped in to help
but schools remain
a major source of food for children and
80 percent of schools report serving
fewer meals
after they shut down last spring a lot
of our families are in a new position of
unemployment
this is new for them not to be able to
go out and purchase food
jessica shelley is cincinnati's director
of student dining services
she has relied on waivers from the
department of agriculture
to distribute food regardless of whether
families have
formally been approved for benefits i
think there might be
students in the district that aren't
getting the nutrition they need each day
and that's why it's so important that
meal boxes and meals are available for
all students
so there is no stigma attached to
getting a school meal and that all
families can feel like they can come
and get the nutrition they need in late
august agriculture secretary sonny
perdue told lawmakers
that allowing schools to feed all
children for free
was beyond his agency's authority less
than two weeks later
purdue reversed course extending the
summer meals program
through the end of december and last
month congressman bobby scott
helped secure funding for the program to
continue
until the end of the school year you
don't have to go to a specific site you
don't have to
show that you're qualified for a free
meal or reduced price meal or full price
meal
you can just get your meal there's
already significant childhood hunger
going on in america today
we can avoid this we can minimize it if
we fund these programs appropriately
at this point it's crucial ryan lopez
was laid off in march
how many kids do you have three he says
free school meals have removed a major
burden on his budget
which is still recovering from the
expiration of
federal unemployment benefits i went
from making
over you know fifteen hundred dollars a
week to
you know now i'm just over four hundred
dollars a week there's no longevity to
any of these plans it just seems like
next week
we'll figure it out next week we'll
figure it out let's figure it out
have a great day and here's another
problem many nutrition programs rely
on meal delivery as a source of revenue
and now that they are serving far fewer
meals
they are also facing budget shortfalls
scale listen to this
cincinnati alone is losing more than one
million dollars
a month boy nancy the numbers are really
hard to hear thank you so much
you know what ryan lopez said i think
was very striking that we're just trying
to figure it out
figure it out figure it out you know the
effects of coved we don't even think
about the ripple effect that
that persuade that pervades many many
facets of your life the financial effect
the emotional effect of not knowing week
to week
how you're going to get by the stuff we
take for granted like eating yeah
like never thinking of never thinking
you're going to be a family in that
situation
because of this virus you are yeah and
no end in sight as we sit here right now
it's
it's heartbreaking